[Applauso]
è la raga siamo su un gioco che non ha
il menu perché è partito che io ho
schiacciato è partito così siamo su
shell
non so se si pronuncia così visto nome
però penso di sì iniziamo allora siamo
io dovrei essere questo personaggio qui
che sta russando fortissimo eruttando
anche journal cosa
va bene sembra mia madre che tenta di
svegliare quando dovevo andare a scuola
[Musica]
dov'è finito a svegliate perfetto
no davvero ci credo silos faticato il
numero uno al mondo e pensavo di essere
io cioè veramente ragazzi che sono si
svegliava ancora sveglia
e ti è andata bene poteva mettere anche
una canzone di darfo gang niente
ragazzi ho finito le idee rotto tutto la
tv se messo nelle fante
[Applauso]
ma è è formidabile sto ragazzo se non
solo capisco cioè quante ciabatte acciai
là dentro fammi capire
l'unico gioco della vita dove ci vuole
una laurea per svegliare il protagonista
cioè fa poverino non ho bisogno d'aiuto
grazie ce la faccio da solo a queste
sono le foto della casa quello che
mangia una ciliegia gigante c'è lui che
si fa un self i davanti a due cose tipo
dinosauri se lui sopra una collina tutti
incazzati sto gioco è lui che prende una
ciliegia simpatico testa robe un aiuto
devo far bere l'acqua al tiro ma ci ha
provato la stazione
[Musica]
dovevo farlo adesso
molto chiaro ma occhio occhio perfetto
[Musica]
duro come la morte a svegliarti è zio da
dove ha tirato fuori questa madonna
sì ma esattamente cosa mi significa
perché sei una palla di fuliggine ha
chiesto tizio con le mani giganti gianni
morandi ragazzi il fatto ma perché vuole
la tua ciliegia ma chi è ok c'è la
ciliegia la prendo va bene
provai a prendere la tua amata ciliegia
cosa ragazzo gioca non ha veramente non
lo capisco ve lo giuro
cosa sta cercando di cal devo cercare di
raggiungere la ciliegia dimmi tu
[Musica]
neanche quei suggerimenti ci riesco a
farselo da esatto dalla parte opposta
[Risate]
cosa diavolo sta giocando lega ma chi è
ma chi è su tizio e vabbè allora
quindi si passa di livello in livello
così molto chiaro quindi l'obiettivo del
gioco è raggiungere la ciliegia è tratto
e pure sporca mi piace quando una delle
rom e non si capisce niente di quello
che sta dicendo prova bene aggiungere
adoratissima ciliegia però fai e scott
il albero stato è l'albero più brutto
che abbia mai visto e cosa fa incammina
sull'albero perfetto e va bene
occhio occhio fra esattamente quello che
non doveva succedere ma va bene cioè
sembra il caso di dell'era glaciale che
non raggiunge mai la la ghianda uguale
[Musica]
che bello adesso la in prova va bene se
è la cosa più allucinante che io abbia
mai visto in tutta la mia ricche gioco è
ok
che roba non potevano portarlo sul
canale regala geniale devo raggiungere
star ciliegia molto simpatico carino
capisco quindi sì l'ho vista zio arriva
arrivo ma una domanda chi è questo tizio
tu chi sei sei una palla di fuliggine
posso parlarci io vi giuro capisco meno
di prima se parlo con la gente quindi
non parliamo allora proviamo a parlare
col tizio ciao cosa adesso no non quello
sì va bene quando parlano non si capisce
una sega parole cammina su tizio non
funziona neanche così prova a lanciare
il tuo amico
[Musica]
ios alto sopra mio amico va bene tira il
velo tirano tirano esatto o perfetto
riesce a entrare
[Musica]
qualcosa mi dici di no proviamo a fare a
capurso anche far spostare il cartello
anni amico spossa cartelli ma di
mangiare ma cos'è amia dissotterrato il
cartello va bene
[Musica]
grazie cosa faccio adesso lo sposto meno
il tizio col cappello molto chiaro
saltaci sopra ok è molto riuscito a
saltare sul cartello perfetto regala un
genio potresti lasciarmi la ciliegia per
favore
[Musica]
quanti acidi il creatore visto gioco hai
veduto veramente troppo a sambuca prima
di creare sta roba
la vuoi mollare st ciliegia magari a
niente dov'è che è finita ma è finita in
testa sto tizio posso prendere la mia
maledettissima ciliegia per favore
prendi al volo gigi ha prendi il mio
amico
prendilo che non è mio amico perché mi
fotte le rose proprio il tipo se n'è
andato ed è tornato in pietro va bene ok
ha dato a era più semplice del previsto
ma per chi è
ma cosa va per chi è puoi mangiare la
per mangia mangia
[Musica]
no regalo capisco un'altra intro cosa
niente la morale della favola è che la
ciliegia la prende sempre nella prendi
tour a prendere l'altro va bene non
capisco cosa di chi diavolo e sta gente
mela vuoi dare con la maledetti scusate
le file più grossa di te va bene e mi sa
che non la prende più zio è come faccio
devo scegliere il volatile milioni e tra
questi c'è un pulcino spappolato un coso
grossissimo che non credo possa volare
per questo secondo me moda trova questo
modo partiamo da un'orca vacca cosa vedo
cos'è dove devo andare esattamente ma
chi è sto tizio con la mano gigante
niente alla camera finirà mai
aiuto torchia vacca difatti a passare
per favore grazie qualcuno mentre sto
giocando qualcuno nei commenti mi trova
un senso staro che cosa rappresenta per
voi questo gioco fatevi sono curioso per
me rappresenta l'incarnazione è proprio
umana della lsd secondo me poi non
capisco senso è la mappa berna stiamo
esagerando quale gatti fatte passare per
cortesia
grazie molto gentili per sé non
spingermi indietro che mi date fastidio
di massacro grazie quanto andato lontano
quell'affare ho mica un'ora
s'è schiantato ci siamo schiantati 22
posso prendere la mia ciliegie insomma
patata in oro mesto konko 6
[Musica]
noi siamo finiti
è una gara a chi la prende prima 321
resto niente non c'è verso me la vivo e
la magagna che fastidio celebro giuro
[Musica]
non è vero
era una fake ciliegia era una bomba
va bene te la puoi tenere il suo ci ha
ripensato dovresti anche un po togliere
la lista vabbè io te l'ho detto
[Musica]
no ragazzi non te lo giuro ciao pochi
neuroni di mio mi sto perdendo non ha
non ha senso ma per caso a qualcuno di
voi suo gioco non ricorda tipo di amici
immaginari di casa foster qualcuno se lo
guardava quel cartone me lo guardavo
solo io sono arrivati a questo punto c'è
un tronco strano c'è scritto non toccare
però la ciliegia la vorrei prendere
quindi ora tocco tocco io non tocchi
tocco io a toccare la ciliegia gli ha
detto così credo dov'è andato a finire
potresti darmela per favore che già
avevo io all'inizio del gioco a cesena
un tool lancia lo fa mangiatelo che con
una parola siete a ok perfetto
ciao zio occhio che magari già scritto
pericolo di morte sono molto io va bene
[Musica]
ci si appresta a mano gigante di
qualcuno che si porta via la ciliegia
non ho ancora capito di chi è
prima della fine dei nostri tempi si
scoprirà chi è sto tizio e gianni
morandi lega io ve lo dico lo so già
alle mani enormi a frate questo sembra
stewie solo la faccia però è vietato il
passaggio solo a me va bene
potreste stare zitti mi date fastidio
grazie non posso staccare le radici
degli alberi scuotere gli alberi si è
smontato un cartello
e io che pensavo interessasse quella
roba lì va bene c'è un cartello a c'è
un'altra zona ma non puoi toglierti
dalle palle ogni volta che va da qualche
parte che fastidio non ho capito cosa ha
detto ma credo abbia detto stai lì puoi
sentire questa roba
tu ti mangi qualsiasi cosa qualsi che
schifo sembra un ragno zio commuovere
questi affari scommette
[Musica]
mi fa troppo morire il suo gioco
cosa vuoi tu e mia questa cosa me ne
faccio di sta roba a mangio io mangio a
caso va bene capito
ok ma non posso sì posso muovermi esatto
dove sono diverse non sono più lui e
sono diverso non mi vedi che sono
diverso mi fai passare non ci è cascato
purtroppo qualità park caccia baccalà
pro mangiare quello rosa vediamo cosa ci
da quello rosa rosa mista di importante
era perfetto ma il giorno mangio io come
maglia color rosa perfetto ma perché
andiamo al e sono lì non mi riconoscerà
mai chadaj ancora come ha fatto
riconoscermi puoi andare a mangiarti
quella roba lì per favore mangia toto
regalo sta bene ma lo diventa un ragno
anche lui
esatto molto più carino vai aprea e ma
credo che debba andare via
ciao lo vedi che lui è diverso prendi la
velocità
dalla ciliegia zio dove vai questo è
scemo non devo fare così devo tappare la
bocca a sti tizi stato fare ho capito
però insetticidi che ho capito zitti
ora che le tappo tutto in teoria poi il
tipo dovrebbe fare qualcosa in teoria
[Musica]
posso muovermi ma sono spariti tutti
vai prende la vera inter lato ci sei non
cadere non cadere sempre gianni bassa la
rottura di tre quarti perché mi sa che c
è un panel culetto aerei etc iran e dino
subito
bene è morto
chi è stato con budino gigante l'eni
mancava sta roba senta signor coutinho
ragazzi questo era il primo bisogno di
uccelli mi piace un sacco un po meno le
ciliegie mi stanno un po meno simpatiche
però spero che vi sia piaciuto primi
episodi fatemi sapere se volete continua
non me ne frega niente se non volete o
meno e lo faccio perché tutti su youtube
debbano fare quello che vogliono e non
accontentare solo il pubblico ma per
questo video sta diventando motivational
ma che cento ed iscrivetevi bei ragazzi
[Musica]